Це Михайло Весельський - засновник школи майбутнього в селі Радовель,  на Житомирщині.
А це Роман Іваненко - автор ідеї перетворення села Бобриця, що під Києвом,
на казкове селище. Обоє  - успішні бізнесмени.
Михайло займається нерухомістю та оптово-роздрібною торгівлею.
Роман - економіст і банкір. Обом українцям не байдуже, в якій громаді жити.
Тож на місцевих виборах восени 2020-го вони пішли в політику,
аби успішний досвід розвитку своїх сіл застосувати до всієї громади.
Останній дзвоник для випускників  біотехнологічного ліцею "Радовель"
перетворився на справжній фестиваль для усіх селян. На великій сцені -
і народні співи, рок-музика, і театральні постановки.
Ще три роки тому ці діти взагалі не мали можливості для творчого розвитку.
Тепер в оновленій школі чимало спортивних, танцювальних
та творчих гуртків, яким позаздрить навіть столичний школяр.
Ідея змінити концепцію навчання та приділити увагу саме творчому мисленню
дітей належить Михайлу Весельському меценату та бізнесмену,
а ще випускнику цієї ж школи. Після ремонту власним коштом
і відкриття ліцею три роки тому він не припинив його фінансувати.
Біля мільйона, мільйон двісті тисяч гривень в місяць.
Мені дуже хотілося б скорочувати, бо ось ці витрати вони суттєві,
але з іншого боку, коли дивишся на зміст, то розумієш, що треба ще додавати,
щоб був повноцінний комплект який був.
Я хочу,  щоб були створені умови для зміни свідомості людей.
У цей час під Києвом, у Білогородській громаді, до якої входить
казкове село Бобриця, проходять стратегічні сесії.
Селяни, яких надихнули позитивні зміни в Бобриці, не стримують своїх мрій:
від відкриття крафтових ярмарків та кафе з місцевими смаколиками -
до вирішення звичайних побутових проблем,
як-от побудова каналізації. Такими вони бачать села майбутнього.
А ще знайти спільну мову з власниками рогатої худоби..
Впевненості їм додає те, що в сусідній Бобриці активна громада на чолі
з Романом Іваненком шість років тому починала саме з мрії.
Тепер село втілило свою - з концепцією розвитку спорту,
мистецтва та збереження природи.
Мене всі запитують: чому ти це робиш.
Складно пояснити. Той хто розуміє, той розуміє, а кому треба пояснювати,
тому і вже і не треба пояснювати.
У нас є історія України - це все про те, чому у нас не вийшло.
Мене це, чесно кажучи, трохи втомлює, читати ту стару історію,
я читаю і роблю висновки.  Головне - дати людям можливість,
щоб вони повірили в себе, бо у нас є така самоцензура,
коли збираєш такі стратегічні зустрічі, і людям говориш: "Давайте,намрійте собі,яке ви хочете бачити село за 7-10 років".
і люди самі зрізають власні мрії,
бо не вірять, що може бути щось хороше.
І головне до них приїхати і пояснити:  От мрійте! Вважайте, що все можливо.
На цих зустрічах Роман вже не як активіст, а як політик.
Восени він став депутатом Білогородської сільської ради від партії "Європейська солідарність".
Партія має шість з 26 місць у місцевій раді.
Згідно з законом про вибори, у громадах з понад десятьма тисячами мешканців,
депутат не може бути самовисуванцем.
Тож заради змін у громаді Роману довелось звикати до партійного життя.
Тобі говорять, що десь в Чернігівській області твої однопартійці щось начудили
і ти тепер теж винуватий. Чи зручно? Ні.
Чи нормалізує процес? Так, бо партія на це звертає увагу.
Все, що я побачив - це все очікувано, я нічого не бачив нового,
я  йшов, щоб нормалізувати процес. І навчити всіх працювати разом.
Немає влади і громади, є лише громада. Питання в тому, кого ви делегуєте.
Громада Бобриці довірилась Роману. Адже за роки його активізму селище змінилось:
тут з'явилися нові зупинки, освітлення, збільшилась кількість велодоріжок
та сучасних скверів. Пожвавилось і життя в селі: почали проходити кінофестивалі
та скульптурні симпозіуми. Їх фінансують частково з місцевого бюджету,
а частково з фонду активних односельчан. Ідея об'єднати небайдужих селян
також належить Роману. Окрім того, він так би мовити навчив місцеву владу
співпрацювати з бізнесом. Так, у Бобриці з'явився кінний клуб.
В Бобриці допомогли підібрати ділянку землі,
щоб відповідала цільовому призначенню і нашому спорту.
Поруч ліс і житловий масив,
де багато дітей, які будуть тренуватись. Є така думка,
що коні - це елітний вид спорту, ми намагаємось це зробити доступним.
Бобриця розміщена за 20 кілометрів від Києва, і тут чимало маєтків заможних киян.
Як і Романа, який десять років тому побудував тут свій дім, людей приваблює
територія села: тут і озера, і ліси. Втім, до будь-яких новобудов
чи бізнесу, який заходить в село, спільні вимоги:
зокрема, не нашкодити природі. Наприклад, жодних парканів на березі озера.
Пляж має залишатися вільним для всіх, як це і передбачено законом.
В якийсь момент я зрозумів, що країна складається
не з тих людей, що сидять в Верховній Раді, Кабміні, а з кількох тисяч громад.
І от якщо в кожній громаді все буде добре красиво,
то не так і важливо, що в центрі країни відбувається на Грушевського і на Банковій,
тому наразі я нічого не думаю,
хочу показати історію успіху на рівні громади
і щоб люди повірили в себе.
Не за обіцянки, а за конкретні дії проголосували і мешканці Радовеля,
коли побачили в бюлетені ім'я Михайла Весельського.
Він ледь не в останню мить долучився до місцевих виборів
і з партією "Країна" завів до Олевської міської ради 5 депутатів.
Я був глибоко переконаний на той момент, що можу вплинути
на розвиток цілої громади і ми можемо зробити прецедент
до нового управління громадою,
що може забезпечити суттєві зміни в громаді.
Це була надія, і з цим я йшов.
Та нині у сесійній залі Михайло вже не як політик, а як радник.
Після пів року свого депутатства він склав повноваження.
Коли почалась робота, я зрозумів,
що це для мене складний формат роботи,
і він більш бюрократичний, і багато питань виникає,
з якими я фізично не можу розібратись.  Якщо я приходжу на сесію, де 150 питань,
то я маю знати достеменно кожне питання:
про що воно, яке має бути рішення сформоване
з точки зору мого світогляду, моїх поглядів,
а не просто так, що так потрібно. І мене почало це дуже турбувати,
що я розумів, що заходжу на поле, де не можу бути ефективним.
Михайло Весельський продовжив розвивати те, з чого і починав свою меценатську роботу.
Це, як він каже, перетворення Радовеля в успішне село щасливих і здорових людей.
Нині на черзі відкриття лікарні. В коридорах пахне свіжим ремонтом,
а в кабінетах виблискує нова техніка.
Наповнити лікарню усім можливим медобладнанням -
таке завдання поставив перед собою меценат. Тут буде і сучасна стоматологія,
і офтальмологічний кабінет, і рентген.
Та найбільше бізнесмен радіє цьому приладу,
який моніторить поставу людини і зможе відслідковувати динаміку її зміни.
Ми промоніторили повністю всіх дітей:
50% дітей мають сколіози різного ступеня і плоскостопія,
порушення постави. І за рахунок цього обладнання ми будемо дивитись,
яка динаміка, бо в школі змінюємо технологію навчання,
бо діти втрачають здоров’я і ми хочемо це змінити.
І це обладнання буде константувати всю динаміку.
А ось так без жодного дотику лікар буде заходити і виходити з операційної.
Це приміщення має кисневе забезпечення, відповідно до останніх медичних стандартів.
Тут же, на другому поверсі, і палати стаціонару, і  душова кабіна в кожній палаті -
мрія ледь не кожного пацієнта державної клініки.
Наразі меценат думає, як зробити майбутні послуги максимально
доступними для селян. Можливо, Радовель стане ще й першим селом,
де усі мешканці матимуть страхову медицину.
Хочемо створити касу громади, куди люди будуть вносити
фіксовані суми і яка буде покривати лікування чи медичне обстеження.
Це один варіант, а други - говоримо зі страховими.
Тобто потрібно буде механізм знайти, і ми над цим працюємо.
Здавалося б, такі стратегічні рішеня було б легше впроваджувати
з депутатським посвідченням. Втім, за пів року роботи в раді Михайло вирішив,
що його шлях - це експериментаторство, і громада
підтримує його
в цьому, як і у рішенні піти з влади.
По його правилам і принципам він би повинен був себе віддавати повністю,
а якби так, то Радовель пішов на інший план.
І я думаю, він вибрав Радовель, бо це його рідне село. І з цього почав.
Він хоче і змінити і саму освіту в Україні,
хоче приклад показати, і тут багато експериментальної роботи хоче.
Як і школа, приміщення лікарні повністю інклюзивне.
Всього два поверхи, але є ліфт для маломобільних людей та батьків з дитячими візочками.
Аби відкрити лікарню, меценату ще треба вкласти в неї понад 12 мільйонів гривень…
А це не означає переплюнути себе і свої можливості?
Я не знаю, я про це не думаю, а завжди думаю, коли щось роблю,
як це можна зробити максимально можливо на сьогодні.
Тоді це буде крок в завтрашній день,
в післязавтрашній.  Якщо сьогодні робити в минуле, то немає сенсу.
Депутат місцевої ради - це волонтерська робота,
тож навіть символічної заробітної плати ні Роман Іваненко,
ні Михайло Весельський не отримували. Обоє бізнесменів
переконані, що до влади треба йти лише тоді, коли маєш чималий
управлінський і підприємницький досвід. І відповідно
саме ним хочеш поділитися з іншими.
А ті ганебні випадки, коли депутати вирішували за рахунок
влади свої бізнес-інтереси мають залишатися в минулому.